[Music]
imagine
that you could shed your skin like a
snake
how long would it take what would happen
to scars and
acne and why would
some people shed more than others
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if you shed your skin like a snake
snakes shed because they grow out of
their skin but
did you know that you shed two
yeah you constantly regenerate the outer
layer of your skin
the epidermis new skin cells form
at the bottom of the epidermis and
travel up to the top
pushing out your old skin cells you
replace about 500 million skin cells
every day you probably don't notice your
skin falling off because
that happens so gradually but in this
hypothetical scenario
all your old skin would build up into
one
dead layer and peel off
would this be the ultimate glow up or
a tedious chore the process of shedding
is called ectasis and it happens
in three stages first you'd notice your
skin getting
duller and darker this is the
pre-shedding phase
your body would need a lot of energy as
it gears up to remove
an entire layer of skin at once
you'd start feeling tired and irritable
and
you'd lose your appetite you'd want to
cancel
all of your plans for the next
one to two weeks you'd prefer to be
alone
yeah you heard me right the pre-shedding
phase would take
up to 14 days now this would be a good
time to binge watch a tv show or
dig into that book you've always said
you were going to read
you'd also want to work from home while
the upper layer of your skin
loosened but working from home
is not an option for everyone so
workplaces
would need to have special sick days
just for shedding
after spending a miserable week
pre-shedding
your new skin would be ready to shine
thankfully shedding would only last a
couple of days
when snakes shed they find a rough
surface to create a tear near the snout
then they use that rough surface to keep
their old skin
in place as they wiggle out of it
so you would create an opening on your
forehead
and peel your old layer of skin off
but you'd have to be careful you
couldn't just peel off
all of your old skin at once if you shed
too quickly you could damage your new
skin
so you'd remove a little each day
after a couple of days of careful
shedding
you'd reach the final stage the after
shed
and you'd feel like a brand new person
you would say goodbye to
hyperpigmentation
surface level scars and any acne you had
before you started shedding
it wouldn't cure your acne and you'd
still get breakouts if you're prone to
acne but
shedding would be like hitting the reset
button on your skin
as for wrinkles well the middle layer of
your
skin is responsible for those pesky
lines but
a fresh layer of outer skin could reduce
the appearance of fine lines
and your new skin's dewy glow would
help you look younger but
what about tattoos well tattoos
deposit ink in the middle layer of your
skin the dermis and
since you'd only shed the outer layer of
your skin the
epidermis your tattoos would be safe
when you finished shedding you'd have a
long
human-shaped shell of yourself and
there would be specific ways to dispose
of this
skin material maybe you could even
compost it
the whole shedding process would be
pretty intense
so how often would you have to do it
well some snakes shed once
a month but most snakes only shed
a handful of times a year it also
depends on
age diet and environment
you'd shed more often when you were
younger because you'd be
outgrowing your skin as you age you'd
shed less
but you'd also shed if you gained or
lost weight
or during pregnancy now
what if your skin didn't shed completely
it's called disectasis and it happens to
snakes
you might not shed all your skin because
your diet could be lacking some
nutrients
and skin infections can cause irregular
shedding
with our diets today dissectasis would
be
a common issue but doctors would be able
to help
humidity helps snakes shed so you could
always go to a spa
specifically designed to help people
shed
society would have to adjust if we
started shedding our skins like snakes
and while we still shed our skins
gradually
right now who knows what the future
might hold
the human body is evolving slowly
what might we look like in hundreds of
thousands of years
well that's a story for
another what if